new evolve DLC on the way Mary just
around the corner pretty excited Chris
for new hunters one new monster let's
run them down talk about what's cool
what's maybe not so cool and let's are
we starting with the bug guy yeah well I
mean we have to start with the craziest
thing that happened which is there's a
there's a bug man there's a bug man and
not only is he a bug man but he has a
bug friend he does it's like as little
healing drone it heals like one person
on the team it's pretty useful but not
really in combat because the monster
actually controller says you can send
the healing drone to revive a Down
survivor and you go to the other one
boom they're back but that's his like
secondary method of healing his first is
actually the Keeling burst the thing
that every medic has but there's a twist
there's a leech gun in this one so he's
actually a damage dealing medic is the
first damage dealing that it cos goals
do damage more damage she does leeches
goes into the peeling burst three shots
on the monster you get to be over it's
incredible like it really encourages you
to be in the mix and landing shots on
the monster like perching on the side is
not really the best tactic with slim
because you want to be landing shots and
has the biggest radius of any medics
heal burst and if you're in there and
doing it like you're that's how you're
gonna keep your team alive yep he's also
got a spork loud gun helps when you're
in the mix Xuan things up which is what
slim is meant to do we also got crow
he's a freaky little looking guy he's
got those sweet goggles like give him
one more light he's practically like Sam
Fisher he's the trapper uh he looks like
one of these tracker guys who's out in
the wilderness for like ages and he made
friends with a bat ray he looks like a
Mongolian man for some reason to me and
he does he has a pet named Toby yeah
that falconry convention sweet he's got
yeah he's got like a little Sudan he
looks great um goby is not like Daisy it
is not a fifth player uh he can't revive
or anything like that but he's pretty
sweet you just send him out in a
direction and he highlights anything
below many animals and the monster but
his real interesting trick is his two
guns they both function differently if
you just fire them or if you hold down
and charge the shot that's correct he's
got a rifle that obviously just does
quick
but if you hold it down it pierces
through the monsters armor into direct
damage which is pretty clutch if think
it's crazy I mean you can have a monster
that's rolled away shield it up but
still doesn't have a lot of health you
don't have to choose for all that shield
you just have to have Pro popping in
with those charged shots the other gun
that he has is a real mobility control
kind of thing it's a stasis gun that's
it does has the same kind of effect as
the stasis grenades but he fired at the
monster short bursts slowed down a
little bit but that big long burst and
you'll slow it down for like a serious
amount of time he's obviously got the
mobile Libya dude the stasis is like the
most annoying thing as a monster now his
hating also we got Sonny who has a
pretty new type of mobility help it's a
boost gun that kind of helps your
jetpack and it kind of refuel zit
immediately if it also sends you flying
yes Sonny's the support and so if you're
if she's zapping you with that like pink
Ghostbuster beam then your jetpack is
gonna be supercharged your doubled your
debt jetpack dash is super effective so
it's like the will you just get over
here already bean she also has a robot
shield you just kind of just send it out
and it's it stays where you put it and
then it shields the last person the
monster head yeah it's a little drone so
it's basically what does that force a
monster to do cuz he as soon as the
monster is hitting someone that drew a
range of that drone that drones gonna be
shielding them automatically and then
she's obviously got the cloak but
there's another interesting thing she
has which is a nuke it's like this
grenade launcher that just makes these
like many huge nuke explosions and it's
really satisfying just it's like you
just doesn have a huge clip but it does
huge damage I think the the official
site says it's the highest damaged
handheld weapon so it's probably behind
the orbital strike or the next gun the
assault we're gonna talk about but Sonny
packs a punch and is also like really
cheery that's gotta believe Sonny has a
little bit of robot help Torvald the
assault is like mmm sixty percent robot
he's more robot than me he's just like
this man torso with sick tattoos and a
beard and he was like whatever I don't
wear armor most of me is robot cuz I got
mauled by a monster real bad we can
rebuild him but we want him to kill
and till he does mortar launchers these
things sort of you know great for
engaging at range but also you can shoot
in straight up when the monsters on top
of you and just rain down explosions
that's his sort of heavy hitting weapon
but when he's up close there's an
automatic shotgun it's really nice it's
got a really good feeling you hit it
once you blast out all your shotgun
shells at once it feels really good it
does a [ __ ] ton of damage especially if
it's like any animals in the area that
are coming towards you and basically
take them down with one foot little
street sweeper action yeah and also the
shotgun you know obviously has that
spread but used with Torvalds shrapnel
grenade shrapnel grenade punches holes
in the monster and so that combined with
the shotgun blast and you're dealing
some damage what I was told was these
four are the heaviest damage dealing
group so far so when you pick slim crow
sunny and Torvald you're dealing the
most damage so far of any for hunters
together you're packing a big punch and
you need it because the new monster
behemoth the most armored the most
health of all the monsters we've seen so
far it's like a suit super tank frog
monster he's hard today I identify I'd
say he's got like little Lobster look to
him as well do big claws in which she
does damage but then he just gets the
weirdest mobility he turns into a ball
he rolls around in this molten ball and
when that ball rolls over you org into
you it does damage yes picks up speed a
little bit especially when you're going
downhill so it kind of seems like a real
obvious like oh there's just this giant
fire trail to follow the monster but the
behemoth can still be a little elusive
if you use your sneak if you use your
mobility he also has a move called
Fisher it's pretty interesting it's
basically he bashes the ground and
anything in its path shoots up with kind
of like fiery hot lava yeah it gets
damaged and that also regardless of what
sort of level you're on I think so if
you hit it into a wall and people are on
top of that platform fishers gonna go
through it it's still gonna hit damage
it's like a little fan attack this is
good for combining with the rock wall
which is a really interesting ability
because not only does it can it trap
hunters close to you so you can punish
them but it can separate hunters from
the rest of the pack so you can focus on
one and it can also just straight-up
block them from following you so you can
make an escape in addition he's got a
molten lava bomb it's just a real
area-denial kind of thing also it's just
huge lava bombs out and then men mini
lava bombs bhama and they kind of
persist in the environment so you can
make an area really off-limits to
hunters even more so then say the
Banshee mines from the Kraken because
those sort of follow and explode these
things persist in one particular place
Hunter's don't want to go to his main
area where you want to hit him isn't
actually his head it's his stomach you
might have noticed those gangly
intestines hanging out girl button you
he is disgusting so that's actually
where you want to shoot him we won't
shoot him in the belly right in the tum
tum that's my weak spot to nobody crawls
around so it's hard to get there but
that's where you want to shoot him but
the grossest thing about the mean of the
thing we have to talk about is the
tongue grab yap gross yeah what's your
tongue grab noise well that's pretty
good yeah look Vicky meth make some
gross noises and the tongue grab who is
this like it doesn't look like a frog
tongue it looks like this naughty hickey
you can see it for yourself but it grabs
a hunter it's sort of a skill-shot like
the rates abduction it grabs a hunter
but it doesn't like whip them and bring
them in like scorpion from Mortal Kombat
like it kind of flicks them towards you
and they're like whoa fly through the
air they have time to anticipate the
fact that you're waiting for them bad
news bad news behemoth uh Mary for new
hunters one new monster in the dlc it's
coming out on March 31st there's also
two maps I believe that's coming out
along with this those are free gonna be
available to everybody that's a great
drop in ah that's one of the things I
like about their approach to dl see the
maps are free the audience is not
divided even if you don't pay for the
monster you can still fight the monster
and that enhances your experience gives
you some variety it's a really good
decision on their part to make sure that
you're not dividing the audience you're
you're able to play with Sonny or with
crow or slim you will see
behemoth we will fight with him whether
or not you give them money it's an
essential way to do DLC now especially
with evolve with this get a deeper
gameplay experience but you don't have
to spend also if you feel like the game
is actually changing and taking and
continuing to be sort of lively and
updated and and new just as a player
that's going to keep you interested I'm
personally still playing involve matches
on the weekends in my spare time so I'm
looking forward to trying out these new
hunters and of course the big behemoth
and nasty tongue Drebin wow yeah
you